George Pell is the most senior Roman
Catholic Church figure anywhere in the
world to be jailed for child sex
offenses in 2018 he was convicted of
abusing two thirteen-year-old choir boys
in the late 90s and given a six year
jail sentence
now he's appealing to Australia's
highest court to have that conviction
overturned his lawyers argued too much
weight was placed on the credibility of
Pels accuser and not enough on other
witnesses and after losing an appeal
last year this is his final chance to
clear his name and be released from
prison it's very hard but if these
things in particular it's hard to
predict where four of the seven judges
will go but he's certainly going into
Tuesday with a good chance of being
freed he'll was a priest in rural
Australia before quickly rising through
the ranks from Archbishop of Melbourne
and Sydney to a cardinal in charge of
the Vatican's finances campaigners for
sexual abuse victims are worried if he
does walk free it may stop others from
speaking out I think that there is
definitely the potential for is to have
a devastating impact on many who may not
many who may lose faith in the criminal
justice system the ruling is being
delivered in the middle of the most
important week in the Catholic calendar
when 1.3 billion members celebrate
Easter if Paul's conviction is
overturned he could walk free from
prison within hours
Pell has continued to maintain his
innocence but whatever the court decides
its findings will be significant
bringing to an end a five-year long
legal saga that millions have been
following across the world Nicola gage
al Jazeera Sydney